antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs bonsoir et bienvenue sur le
plateau d'antenne 2 est la une ce soir
nouveau rebondissement dans la sphère
lüscher rebondissements de temps
aujourd'hui ce matin publication du
rapport barba dans les colonnes du
figaro cet après midi andré giraud le
ministre de la défense verse le rapport
au dossier de l'instruction dans
quelques instants
tout sur le rapport l'ambiance à
l'assemblée et les derniers commentaires
les cinq irlandais du caveau panaméen et
xun inculpé l'un d'eux un gros bonnet de
l'irs eileen ton à londres margaret
thatcher remercie publiquement la france
pour cette prise d'armes historique la
modernisation de l'agriculture au
conseil des ministres en 1992 il faudra
plus de matière grise aux jeunes pour
s'installer niveau bta
la rançon de la compétition européenne
football toutes petites qualification de
bordeaux face à lille autrement 0 1 but
de ferreri ce soir toulouse et à
leverkusen pour une qualification bien
difficile
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel carton marcel fontaine jean
paul kauffmann jean louis normandin
d'antenne 2 et roger auque les otages
français au liban n'ont toujours pas été
libérés
la sphère lüscher rebondit tout a
commencé ce matin dans les colonnes du
figaro où nos confrères ont publié le
rapport barbares relatifs aux ventes
d'armes françaises à l'iran publication
qui défrayait la chronique car le
rapport en question était encore classé
confidentiel défense
cet après midi intervention d'andré giro
le ministre de la défense qui annonce
aux députés la déclassification du
rapport désormais la pièce est versée au
dossier de l'instruction
alors au delà de ces derniers
rebondissements la sphère lüscher ont
une autre dimension dimension politique
pour certains
affaire d'état pour d'autres écoutez
alain juppé le porte parole du
gouverneur seule chose que je dirais sur
ces affaires c'est qu'il ne faut pas
trop les globalisé et tout mélanger il
ya des affaires subalterne avec des
dessus d'ailleurs qui sont carrese
quasiment vide qui sont purement et
simplement des règlements de comptes
personnels
et puis des affaires d'état le fait que
en contradiction formelle avec sa
diplomatie et ses positions
internationales ont vu et au su des plus
hautes autorités
la france est vendu des armes en état
belligérants dans ce conflit rac iran et
plus précisément à l'iran c'est une
affaire d'état
et cela mérite que toutes les procédures
administratives et toutes les procédures
judiciaires se déroule pour qu'on sache
la vérité il faut faire la vérité
précisément que dit exactement le
rapport barba question essentielle car
c'est bien sur ce rapport réalisé par le
contrôleur général des armées qui a mis
le feu aux poudres
le rapport confirme le trafic d'armes
avec l'iran il laisse entendre également
que des sommes de l'ordre de 2 à 3
millions de francs ont été remises à un
proche de charles hernu alors ministre
de la défense
décryptage et explications texte avec
laurent boussier pour le contrôleur
général des armées barba dont le rapport
n'est plus depuis cet après midi classé
confidentiel défense une chose est sûre
500000 obus de 105 est de 155
millimètres ont bien été livrés à l'iran
entre
83 et 86 à l'aide de faux certificats de
destination établi pour le portugal le
brésil la thaïlande et la yougoslavie la
société lüscher a alimenté pendant
quatre ans l'armée iranienne
ce rapport précise que ses exportations
étaient couvertes par le pouvoir
politique et qu'au ministère de la
défense jean françois dubost conseiller
de charles hernu suivait cette affaire
jean françois dubost qui aurait demandé
à daniel dewavrin président de l'uimm
cher de ne pas exporter ouvertement des
munitions en iran au ministère de la
défense outre jean françois dubeau c'est
charles hernu l'ingénieur général plan
le général vautrin et trois directeurs
des affaires internationales auraient
eux aussi étaient au courant des
exportations déguisée de lüscher à
l'elysée c'est l'amiral lacoste alors
directeur de la sécurité militaire qui
aurait alerté françois mitterrand le 21
mai 84 le président lui aurait demandé
d'en parler à charles hernu sur le plan
financier le rapport barba précise que
100 millions de francs auraient été
versées à des intermédiaires italiens et
iranien et que 2,5 à 3 millions de
francs ont été remis à françois diaz un
proche de charles hernu mais aucune de
ces sommes n'a été versée directement au
parti socialiste ou aux autorités du
ministère
aujourd'hui vous en doutez nombreuses
réactions dans les milieux politiques
clermont roy qui était ce matin
l'invitée d'antenne 2 estime que la
justice a été bafouée et que la
démocratie n'a rien à gagner dans ce
genre de règlement de comptes nombreuses
réactions également cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale
l'assemblée où andré giraud le ministre
de la défense a dû faire face aux
questions d'actualité
olivier lerner trois questions trois
réponses andré giraud en vedette
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle claude
l'abbé bruno mégret et pierre joxe ont
interpellé le ministre de la défense sur
la sphère du jour sous des angles
différents comme les partisans de la
paix et les défenseurs des intérêts
français et vous organisez des ventes
d'armes au cul pour financer votre parti
et lorsqu'il s'y opposait que
l'ingénieur général ou droit perdu la
vie je dois vous dire mon indignation
que vous ayez mais les recettes
le nom du généreux qu'est ce qui vous
donne le droit de mêler à cette affaire
la mort du général au bras qu'est ce qui
vous en donne le droit
une prise de bec qui n'ira pas plus loin
andré giroux applaudi par les
socialistes étonnant airs pierre joxe
demande alors aux ministres de lever le
confidentiel défense il affirme que la
sphère ce n'est qu'on pouvait vous et
vous voulez vous authentifier ce texte
ce document publié aujourd'hui dans la
presse est-ce bien votre rapport
un l'authentifier en pouvez vous
authentifier en particulier le passage
où il est écrit aucune somme n'a été
versée au parti socialiste ce qui est la
vérité et je vais vous dire
immédiatement d'ailleurs pour vous
satisfaire que le document auquel vous
faites allusion et déclassifiés au-delà
de cette remise aux normes
administratives les faits évoqués dans
le rapport du contrôle intéresse
l'autorité judiciaire et elle seule
ce rapport est désormais une pièce de
son dossier une pièce seulement et non
sa conclusion
mais la justice passera monsieur le
député et j'espère tout serait d'accord
avec moi pour approuver à l'avance les
jugements qu'elle portera le juge
legrand chargé de la faire était en fait
dès hier soir en possession du fameux
rapport barba il possède également les
pages annexes 8 ou 9 pages qui n'ont pas
encore été publiés par la presse mais je
vous donne rapidement d'autres réactions
dans cette affaire lüscher qui fait
décidément couler beaucoup d'encre le
parti socialiste a décidé de porter
plainte contre ceux qui l'ont
publiquement diffamé le ps je cite ces
propos réaffirme que pas un seul centime
en provenance d'un quelconque trafic
d'armes n'a été perçu par lui autre
réaction celle de charles hernu l'ancien
ministre de la défense charles hernu
furieux écoutez le tout de suite
je me demande est ce que j au jour dans
mon bureau
malheureusement pas ce qui se passe dans
votre vie privée un bon moi j'ai mon
honneur pour moi je viens de m'offrir
leur cesser ce genre de questions
dévastatrice
on n'a pas su comme ça
je me revendique rien voyous j'ai pas
mon but d'armes et cheminement de me
respecter et c'est mon droit aux fêtes
bal baissier voilà jean-louis lesaint de
bonsoir cette journée du 4 novembre
marquent incontestablement un tournant
dans la sphère lüscher est ce que cette
affaire est vraiment devenu une affaire
d'état comme le disait tout à l'heure
monsieur juppé avant tout ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui est grave car pour des
motifs politiques quelqu'un s'est servi
de la presse pour court circuiter
complètement le pouvoir judiciaire
résultats un ministre est obligé de
déclasser un dossier confidentiel
défense qu'il a lu presque in extenso le
matin même dans le journal ce n'est pas
le moindre paradoxe de ces affaires qui
empoisonnent la vie politique depuis
quelques temps et quand il n'y a pas de
dossier
une rumeur suffit à faire la faire
aujourd'hui d'autres rumeurs circulent
par exemple que jacques chirac se serait
arrêtée lors de son voyage en nouvelle
calédonie sur l'atoll d'hao où sont
retenus les faux époux tu ranges
uniquement pour bien faire savoir à
l'elysée que matignon un dossier en
béton sur la fière greenpeace de son
côté l'elysée aurait suffisamment
d'informations pour faire trembler
charles pasqua comme on dit un partout
la balle au centre
pas sûr car chaque jour apporte son lot
de rumeurs la démocratie gagne tél oui
si la justice peut aller jusqu'au bout
avant la campagne présidentielle
non s'il s'agit simplement pour les
protagonistes de jouer à se faire peur
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que cette
affaire comme les autres affaires
ternissent un peu l'image de la classe
politique c'est certain mais on l'a
constaté de plus en plus d'hommes
politiques de droite comme de gauche
considèrent qu'il est grand temps de
mettre un terme à l' escalade
on a remarqué cet après-midi le ton
mesuré du ministre andré giraud qui
répondait à une question tranquille de
pierre joxe
tout le monde commence à comprendre que
l'accumulation d'affaires nuit à la
classe politique dans son ensemble et
que seuls tirent leur épingle du jeu
ceux qui attaquent tous azimuts comme le
pen ou ceux qui ne parlent pas comme
barreiro car tant il est vrai que le
meilleur moyen de ne pas avoir d'
affaires sur le dos c'est encore de ne
pas être aux affaires
on peut tout vous demandez ce soir je
peux vous formuler une dernière question
indiscrète qui a qui a livré et qui a
donné au figaro le rapport barben je
connais le nom mais je les classé
confidentiel défense
merci à brest sans doute la fin d'une
énigme autour du cargo exxon de la
cargaison composée d'armes de munitions
et d'explosifs étaient destinés
intégralement à l'ira provisoire le
procureur de la république de brest
avait confirmé l'information dès hier
soir
aujourd'hui les cinq hommes d'équipage
du caboteur et xun ont été transférés au
palais de justice de paris avant d'être
inculpé et placé sous mandat de dépôt
provisoire selon la bbc
trois d'entre eux seraient de dangereux
terroristes nos confrères anglais ajoute
qu'il s'agit d'un nouveau revers pour
l'ira à londres le point avec philippe
harrouard les cinq irlandais arrêté en
france sont bien des membres de l'ira
munis de passeports volés l'un d'entre
eux est un gros poisson gabriel cleary
changer de la logistique de
l'organisation terroriste
les policiers irlandais qui ont
collaboré avec les français sont
persuadés que toutes les armes étaient
destinées à l'irlande et devait servir à
une grande offensive menée par lire cet
énorme cargaison représente une somme de
200 millions de francs et le trésor de
guerre de l'ira est presque vide
elle a été chargé quelque part en
afrique du nord on aimait donc
l'hypothèse que ces armes pourraient
être un cadeau du colonel kadhafi est qu
une partie aurait pu être revendue pour
remplir les caisses de l'ira en tout cas
les missiles sam-7 récupéré à bord du
cargo panaméen avaient leur utilité la
branche armée de l'ira et très gêné par
les hélicoptères qui survolent sans
cesse la frontière entre l'irlande du
nord et la république hélicoptère qui se
révèle très efficace pour détecter tout
mouvement depuis longtemps les pilotes
britanniques redoutent l'utilisation de
missiles contre leurs appareils
ceci pourrait expliquer cela cela
montrerait aussi que l'ira entend donner
une dimension beaucoup plus large à son
conflit contre les forces britanniques
après plusieurs déconvenues voilà un
nouveau coup sévère porté à lire à
madame thatcher s'est d'ailleurs
empressé de féliciter officiellement les
autorités françaises pour leur concours
efficace
l'art et la manière de moderniser
l'agriculture ce matin en conseil des
ministres à paris françois guillaume a
présenté son projet de loi agricole
le but de l'opération est visiblement de
promouvoir une entreprise agricole
moderne capable de s'adapter aux
conditions économiques nouvelles pour
s'imposer les agriculteurs devront
désormais avoir la tête bien pleine
car pour bénéficier des aides de l'état
ils vont devoir brandir un diplôme
équivalent du bta le brevet de
technicien agricole
détail important car pour l'instant 10%
seulement des agriculteurs ont le niveau
du bta maryse mano 25 ans c'est par cet
arboriculteur de sa stagiaire une
génération pendant laquelle la formation
les agriculteurs a beaucoup évolué pour
lui l'apprentissage du métier à était
sommaire
l'apprentissage se fait aussi sur le tas
donc en tant que chef d'exploitation bon
on remet en cause bien souvent notre
façon de cultiver ce qu'on est contraint
par des aléas économiques des aléas
climatiques donc même ce qu'on apprend
il faut l'adapter à toutes ces
conditions la différence pour elle c'est
qu'il n'y aura pas d'installation
possible sans diplôme aujourd'hui le
bepa brevet d'études professionnelles
agricoles en 92
le bts brevet de technicien agricole en
clair les agriculteurs devront avoir le
niveau bac pour exercer l'enseignement
agricole va devoir mettre les bouchées
doubles moins de 10% des agriculteurs
ont le brevet de technicien dans cette
maison familiale rurale une filière
privée de l'enseignement agricole
peu d'élèves espèrent obtenir un diplôme
supérieur
je sais bien mais
on fait de vrais moyens et je peux
toujours essayer mais je retiens moi je
pense que tu auras plus facilement
mythique avec un bta qu'avec un débat
pourtant les enseignants sont prêts à
jouer le jeu même s'il devait mettre
quelques réserves sur la nature du
diplôme exigé et sur leurs moyens il
faut être franc je pense que ça va être
difficile mais il faut qu'on nous donne
tous les moyens pour arriver à faire le
maximum de ce que nous pouvons faire
alors le bta et un examen qui est un
autre point de vue très scolaire en fait
les maisons familiales craignent de
perdre leur particularité leur pédagogie
qui s'appuie sur la formation en
alternance a été copié dans l'industrie
seulement voilà le niveau général
d'instruction des agriculteurs français
reste inférieur à celui de leurs
collègues du nord de l'europe
là bas les trois quarts des agriculteurs
ont une formation supérieure la
cohabitation à rude épreuve françois
mitterrand juge discutable certaines
mesures contenues dans le nouveau statut
de la nouvelle calédonie le chef de
l'état fait remarquer qu'un projet
d'autonomie en nouvelle calédonie serait
plus utile dans un climat d'apaisement
ce qui n'est pas le cas en ce moment fin
de citation je rappelle que le nouveau
statut présenté ce matin par bernard
pons est basé sur trois principes
l'autonomie la régionalisation et la
création d'une assemblée coutumière le
pouvoir exécutif sera assurée par un
conseil de dix membres conseil qui
remplacera le haut-commissaire
actuellement en fonction tout de suite
les réactions à nouméa avec l'un de nos
confrères de la sp à prendre ce projet
avec une certaine réserve près pendant
tant d'années qu'on propose au
gouvernement
il faudrait également à ces questions
récemment dans cet après midi à paris
reconstitution d'une affaire qui remonte
à la nuit du 31 août dernier cette
nuit-là souvenez-vous trois jeunes
mineurs avaient été interpellés par des
gardiens de la paix d'une brigade mobile
d'arrondissement interpellations
musclées aux dires des trois jeunes gens
les policiers dont deux sont
actuellement inculpés les aurait malmené
et jouer à la roulette russe avec l'un
d'eux aujourd'hui chacun est resté sur
ses positions mais les pma les brigades
mobiles d'arrondissement qui sont
chargés de patrouiller toutes les nuits
dans paris se retrouve une nouvelle fois
sur la sellette
emmanuel vanier et roger motte ont
essayé de comprendre leur rôle et leur
travail
regardez claque
tu sers interpellation par une
patrouille des bma les brigades mobiles
d'arrondissement de nuit couteau au
point trois hommes avaient tenté de
braquer un magasin au commissariat les
malfaiteurs sont remis à la police
judiciaire
le rôle des bma s'arrête là leur
fonction principale c'est l'arrestation
en flagrant délit un travail délicat
il n'y a pas de dérapage pourquoi parce
que ces gens là sont m 2 et je crois que
c'est ce qu'il faut développer chez ces
garçons c'est la maîtrise le sang-froid
et la réflexion
je veillais de santé superflues non je
dirais que ce sont des flics de bons
flics et qu'on essaye donc de
sélectionner un peu et ensuite de
développer
justement leur maîtrise et sang-froid
dans intervention tous les policiers des
bma sont d'anciens gardiens de la paix
volontaire pour travailler la nuit ils
suivent une formation spécifique
notamment en droit et en manipulation
des armes
six brigades composées chacune de 25
policiers d'une dizaine d'officiers
housse officiers patrouilles chaque nuit
de 23 heures à 6 heures du matin les
rôles des pma sont multiples contrôles
d'identité répression des infractions au
code de la route surveillance des
bâtiments publics et surtout lutte
contre la criminalité
est-ce que parfois vous avez peur
d'intervenir non non plus
il assure
la solidarité avec nos collègues on
n'est pas tout seul dans le véhicule
si on a besoin de renfort ont la balle
n'est jamais seul cette nuit-là meurtre
à barbès
un barman a voulu s'interposer dans une
bagarre il a reçu un coup de couteau en
plein coeur
toute la nuit les brigades mobiles
d'arrondissement rechercheront la
voiture des meurtriers en vain
heureusement sensible
à gauche
à la tête des six brigades nocturne deux
commissaires eux aussi patrouille toute
la nuit
chaque véhicule est autonome les
policiers interviennent la plupart du
temps de leur propre initiative mais
toutes les communications radios sont
enregistrées c'est d'ailleurs le seul
moyen de savoir précisément qui a fait
quoi
au cours des patrouilles les brigades
mobiles d'arrondissement été créé en
l'an dernier elles ont mis trois mille
cinq cents personnes à la disposition de
la police judiciaire
francfort toujours en état de choc au
lendemain de la manifestation qui a fait
deux morts dans les rangs des policiers
après la peur et l'émotion l'heure est
aux certitudes le pistolet saisis chez
l'un des manifestants étaient bien
l'arme du crime à bonn le gouvernement
annonce qu'il va riposter en définissant
des nouvelles mesures de répression
contre les manifestants violents
philippe rochot les autonomes se sont
eux responsables de la mort des deux
policiers s'ils portent des cagoules
c'est pour ne pas être fichiers par la
police qui filme tous les manifestants
le port de ces masques divise la classe
politique le pouvoir veut interdire les
cagoules et réprimer plus fermement ces
manifestations le gouvernement va
riposter après le meurtre de ses deux
policiers
la police ne peut pas rester sans
défense il faut adopter de nouvelles
lois
ainsi le droit de rassemblement serait
remise en question les deux unités
spéciales seraient chargés de réprimer
les manifestations des autonomes les
libéraux les verts et une partie de la
gauche s'oppose tout renforcement des
lois
ils sont pourtant directement impliqués
dans ces affrontements autour de
l'aéroport de francfort car ce sont eux
qui organisait les manifestations
mais cette fois ils ont été débordés par
les autonomes d'autres soutiennent le
problème c'est que les gauchistes se
battent de plus en plus pour des
symboles et le conflit avec le pouvoir
dégénère en violences des deux côtés car
l'état lui aussi se bat pour les mêmes
symboles les partis politiques allemands
condamne tous le meurtre des deux
policiers mais restent divisés sur les
moyens d'y faire face
la presse affirme que ces deux morts ne
seront pas les derniers voyons
rapidement les autres télégramme de
l'étranger ensuite on passe aux sports à
la fiche ce soir beaucoup de choses du
football
nice et de l'automobile alain guilhot le
photographe français qui avait disparu
en afghanistan est localisé il est en
prison à kaboul
la formation humaine les autorités
soviétiques qui précise qu'il fait
actuellement l'objet d'une enquête
alain guyot qui effectue un reportage
sur la résistance afghane avait
semble-t-il été capturés au cours d'une
embuscade tendue par l'armée régulière
dans le nord-ouest du pays
la léger raffermissement du dollar à new
york mais le billet vert est affaibli en
revanche sur les marchés européens sauf
à paris où il s'est échangé à 582 25 à
wall street la tendance était à
l'effritement à l'ouverture de la séance
et à la bourse de paris les valeurs
françaises ont cédé près de 3%
aujourd'hui quatre morts à la suite
d'importantes inondations dans l'est de
l'espagne des pluies torrentielles se
sont abattues sur la province d'alicante
certaines villes ayant refusé jusqu'à
500 litres d'eau au m² vous prévoit
ferrer est coupée orangeraies ravagé des
centaines de personnes ont été évacuées
et la météo ne prévoit pas
d'amélioration dans les prochaines
heures
l'information nous est parvenue en fin
d'après midi pierre seghers poète et
éditeur est décédé aujourd'hui à
l'hôpital henri mondor de créteil
âgé de 81 ans pierre seghers était un
militant inlassable de la course
poétique il avait édité léo ferré
georges brassens seghers avait
d'ailleurs beaucoup de mérite car il
était très difficile d'éditer des
chanteurs parmi les poètes
ecoutez-le l'introduire la chanson
populaire dans une collection poétique
et bien ça a été toute une histoire
ça m'a valu pas mal de colis bête en
revanche six mois après on lui donnait
le grand prix de l'académie française de
la poésie
eh bien il ya plusieurs tests qui ont
été préparées sur brassens et on apprend
ces textes on explique ses textes et en
les chante le football à l'heure
européenne les bordelais se sont
qualifiés tout à l'heure pour le
prochain tour de la coupe d'europe en
battant de justesse les norvégiens de
lindstrom
ce n'est pas à proprement parler une
surprise jean ma mère pour gardent tout
de suite plus petite marge 1 but à 0 et
pourtant les bordelais ont dominé tout
au long de cette rencontre nous allons
d'ailleurs voir tout de suite le but
nous sommes en fin de première mi temps
longue touche de to blend dégagement de
la tête
repéré par ferry ferreri pousse la
défense et prend un mix n le gardien
suédois ferreri est fou de joie il est
vrai que il était discutée dans cette
équipe de bordeaux venir marquer un but
en coupe d'europe c'est toujours
important surtout que finalement ce sera
le but qualificatif pour les quarts de
finale aimé jacquet à ce moment là s est
rassuré il peut malheureusement l'équipe
de bordeaux ne marquera plus rien dans
cette partie les bordelais genou le
rappelle ont tout de même dominé tout au
long de cette partie disons notamment
failli inscrire un but sur une
magnifique tête en deuxième mi-temps de
josé touré
mais la finition n'était pas ce soir
bordelaise même si ici ferreri dont nous
revoyons le vus au ralenti qualifie
l'équipe de bordeaux
le principal c'est de se qualifier nous
allons pas de ce soir toulouse joue à
leverkusen ce n'est pas évident on l'a
dit la qualification sera beaucoup plus
difficile et vous pourrez voir ce match
à 21h35 sur antenne
après le football sur les résultats de
cet après midi il y avait deux français
sur le franc sur le court y en eut du
bien et du moins bon cassoulet thierry
champion
le héros du premier jour est tombé face
à mainz djorf le 21e joueur mondial en
deux sets 6-2 6-3 par contre guy forget
qui avait eu un tirage au sort assez
défavorable n'a pu passer leurs staffs
le messire tête de série numéro 1 de ce
premier au premier tour il est tombé il
faut le dire avec les honneurs puisqu'il
est allé au troisième set
vainqueur du premier set 6 3 guy forget
a fait douter miroslav mecir jusqu'au
bout investir en petite forme et très
moyen dans les changes en s'appuyant sur
un bon premier service forget est allé
jusqu'à la limite mais messire même
fatigué reste tout de même un excellent
joueur de raquette et lorsqu'il faut
sortir le grand jeu
il est toujours là plus une seule balle
de match lui a suffi mais quel échange
un échange très soutenues et très vif et
surtout très offensif qui va se terminer
par une volée en revers faute et de
miroslav mecir c'est très bien fait
c'est du très bon tennis
il monte au filet premier rattrapage de
forger le vaut bien
les sirènes des limitations
l'élimination pardon bravo forget quant
à henri leconte il faut le dire il s'est
aisément débarrassé de l'argentin
bengoetxea en deux sets 6 2 6 1 en ce
moment juste derrière nous et en direct
l'américain pat cash et sur le glaunec
way à ce sujet la zec jeu c'est un des
favoris
voilà le match vient de commencer je
reprends ma petite oreillette est pour
l'instant cash mène 1-0 dans ce premier
fait tout se passe bien pour lui fat
surpris je dirais la logique est
respectée café le score par le petit
bout de la lorgnette et très vite jean
il paraît que vous êtes tombé à la
renverse en voyant des images
d'haltérophilie et bé oui les femmes
jusque là jouent au football au tennis
rugby alors pourquoi pas de
l'haltérophilie le tout c'est de savoir
jusqu'à quel point elles iront quand on
arrivera au poids lourds il faudra se
méfier pour l'heure il y a pratiquement
dans la salle presque autant de
spectateurs voilà attendait jura puis
sur la même [ __ ]
nous allons le voir il ya presque autant
de spectateurs natale qu'il y a deux
compétiteurs certaines sont presque
aussi impressionnante que les hommes
personne n'a dit gros jusque là d'autres
ont par contre un look très féminin
malgré la charge
mais gare à la prise de poids sinon l'on
n'aura plus droit à tout cela et puis
avouez que ça c'est quand même bien
dommage sémillante mais un peu
plantureuse quand même
il est vrai un petit bisou à la fin
quand même elle est sans transition la
météo josé toujours du soleil et elle me
passe devant et pierrette toujours dit
soleil toujours du soleil ont ri c'est
une bonne nouvelle
toujours et c'est tout ce que j'espère
fort comme abc puisque demain il se
taillera la part du lion
la situation vous la connaissez un
anticyclone au dessus des îles
britanniques qui nous protège donc et
qui repousse toute menace de
perturbations et du reste c'est la cause
les inondations actuellement en espagne
je suis comme vous le voyez et bien tous
les nuages se sont logés soit sud de
l'espagne alors demain du brouillard sur
le nord-est des brouillards
particulièrement consistant dans la
vallée de la saône et en bourgogne
ensuite place au soleil qui sera
contrarié de temps à autre par le
passage d'un cumulus mais c'est tout
côté température pas d'évolution ça veut
dire qu'il fera à 11 degrés dans le
triangle nancy strasbourg mulhouse 12 à
lyon 20 encore enfin demain jeudi 5
novembre
pensez aussi vie au triple galop
maintenant il faut aller très vite pire
est à les pronostics du quartier du
tiercé demain on court à vincennes
1 ce sera l'ouverture du meeting d'hiver
de l'hippodrome de vincennes avec un
quartier qui se courra dans le prix
pierre van troyen il s'agit d'une course
longue de 2650 mètres qui réuni un lot
de dix neuf chevaux des trotteurs bien
connu et le célèbre ils sont donc au
nombre de 19
et pourquoi ne pas faire confiance au
favori puisqu'on ne connaît pas encore
vraiment la forme de ses chevaux à cette
époque-ci d'années donc en tête qu'un
seul numéro 16 suivi de 40 hier de 12
quai d'où le numéro 11 quel échelon le
13 qacida dupont le cisq eric le 7è
train du chêne le 8 et koblet 0,5 pour
terminer 16 12 11 13 6 7 8 et 5 ses
premiers furent êtes vous nous faites
encore gagné alors un espérons le
prochain rendez vous d'information 23h05
avec au brier de l'ère serge dassault
sera l'invité du journal demain 6h45
télématin avec roger zabel de retour de
new york barque hautement et catherine
ceylac roland leroy député communiste
répondra aux questions de gérard morin
c'est à 7h45 dans les 4 vérités
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 et à
demain bonsoir
e